hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the saga of
the great paul charles murphy
and the match with uh thomas wilson
barnes has come to an end and
the final score between morphy and
barnes is 19-7
now even though it doesn't appear to be
like uh like some sort of a
great uh success against morphe 1927 is
actually one of the best results uh if
not the best i'm not going to say if
it's the best since it would
maybe spoil the saga but amongst anyone
who played against uh paul morphy so 19
to seven not not a bad deal
and a lot of you have been requesting it
if there if we could make some uh mr
barnes merch and uh
per your request i have added two items
to the
uh to the agar matra swag store it is
the
mr barnes t-shirt and mr barnes mug you
will find it the first link in the
description below will take you to it
now uh that being said let's check out
this one so uh stoneton's next minion is
reverend john owen and he's an extremely
strong player
at some point considered one of the top
10 players in the world uh one of the
strongest
members of the st george chess club and
uh well you'll see you might have heard
of him if you've heard of the owen
defense
well uh this is uh one such game where
this defense is used and it's uh
it's i think it's a very important
historical game as well
so that's why i decided to show this one
and we said that uh
morphe played against a lot of players
when he arrived here in england he
played against
we already saw the games against boden
and barnes uh he's still trying to get a
game against taunton although staunton
keeps avoiding him
he's constantly saying okay we will uh
adjourn the match for
another german but we will uh play it at
some other time
and it probably uh stoneton was trying
to see just how strong morphy was
because even if he lost the morphy
morphy would just go back to
uh to to america and he would have to
stay here
and you know uh uh be ashamed of the
loss as here he has
he does have a lot of authority and uh
they did play two games
so far but it was not a one-on-one game
it was a game where uh john owen here
played with
howard staunton against uh morphy and
barnes they played two such games i'm
still deciding whether to show those
games as they were mostly
uh sort of consultation games not actual
competitive games but
maybe maybe i will show them still
deciding uh but imagine morphia
and barnes playing as one entity it's
just i'm
i'm sure i still haven't checked out the
games but i'm sure those games are
simply the best they're like uh you know
uh
extreme relentless attacking uh you know
with some positional understanding
it's like you know if you've merged
leela and stalkfish or you know
goku and vegeta it's like the the
ultimate fighter morphian barnes
but yeah probably will show them but
we're going to save those two matches
for
those two games for the end of the
morphy's england saga
but here uh a game against john owen the
reverend and we're going to talk about
him a bit more but
before that we're going to check out
this game so morphe with the white
pieces opens with e4
and john owen opens with b6 uh the
owen defense so uh yes it has been
played in this game sorry about that
and okay morphe continues uh with
controlling the center we have d4 bishop
to b7 and now bishop to d3
so if you remember uh i it was the elena
who showed
this game on the channel this is the
beginning of the famous greco game
uh that uh goes if you haven't seen that
video i'll i will put a link to that uh
in the description below but uh in short
it's just uh
giving up the f-pawn offering this black
captures
you deliver check g6 captures and now
finally knight f6 attacks the queen and
here you give up the queen pawn captures
and after knight here this is checkmate
so the famous greco game
uh if you haven't seen it but do check
it out it's quite a lovely video
and also yeah it seems that chess.com uh
did something with the interface the
red uh lights uh the red squares are now
uh
less red and also uh the arrow is
transparent and also yeah we do have
like the green squares the red squares
the greens are some
sort of a lighter green we have the blue
squares and also we have
never before seen yellow squares so i
don't know what we're going to do with
the yellow squares but we're going to
figure something out
so here uh not going for for the famous
f5 but rather owen goes for e6
uh as he is mr owen so he knows what
he's doing with owen's defense
and here morphe goes knight to h3
instead of knights to c3
probably just just being weird trying to
throw
owen off guard uh with c5 uh attacking
the center and c3
uh we have c capture sunday for captures
and the knight to c6 putting pressure on
the pawn here
bishop to e3 morphe defense as we all
know morphe likes to put his bishops on
d3 and e3
and now knight to b4 and uh
it's very interesting that this position
has been never been reached again
but other than that it also shows that
owen understands the the
power of the bishop pair in open games
and he immediately wastes the tempo
going after the light square bishop
and okay morphe continues development we
have knight to c3 and owen
immediately grabs it uh knight captures
uh we have queen captures and now
bishop to b4 pinning the knight uh now
putting pressure on this pawn
that's the idea of the owen defense just
going after this
e4 pawn so morphe castles on pins and
now
bishop captures on c3 so giving up the
other bishop
uh giving up the dark square bishop with
b
captures and now knight to f6 again with
a double attack on e4 and morphy just
advances it's the e5 and he says okay
i'm very happy now
we have knight to d5 and here the
immediate c4 by morphy which is kind of
risky
as this is met with bishop to a6 now
putting pressure here
and now bishop to d2 murphy doesn't want
to give up the dark square bishop we
have rooked the c8 now with the threat
of capturing here
and here morphy played rook 8 to c1
which morphe usually does he just
instantly plays he never
likes to think about a move but there
was the very interesting queen g3
now there is a thread of captures and
also queen captures and g7 is the idea
so probably after characters and
captures we'd have rook fate and bishop
h6
uh yeah black can play black and play
queen e7 and so on
but it's just a very messy position to
have for black white of course is much
better here
but okay after rook c8 we have rook 8 to
c1 morphy not want to do well
long on a move and here owen just
castles with queen to b3
now finally getting out of the way
preparing to capture and the more vs
would give up a rook for two pieces no
questions asked
so 97 owen knows this so he gets rid of
a rid of the knight and now
bishop to b4 again with this pin here
rookie eight open on pins and the rook f
to d1
here we have knight to f5 bringing the
knight into the game
and here morphy just uh launches forward
with the g4 i mean this is uh
this is uh i believe uh strictly the
influence of uh mr thomas wilson barnes
i mean you don't play this unless you
just face
barnes like g4 okay maybe it can be
justified if
the knight was forced to go back and
stay there like forever but here with
the knight being allowed to come to h4
it just seems very very weird and here
morphy
launches forward even further and now we
get to the position from the thumbnail
look at this
if this is not the influence of mr
barnes i i don't know what
what is happening here and now owen just
challenges morphy's
well-extended center he goes for f6 and
now bishop to e1
goes after the knight but uh owen says i
don't mind
f captures an e5 now the queen defends
the knight d
captures an e5 and now queen to e7
and now the the pawn can move even
capture stuff as
the queen is no longer on the same file
as the rook and now knight the g5 by
morphe uh
trying to get uh more weakenings on the
king side
but also just shifting the knight to a
much uh much better uh central e4 square
which now controls a lot of beautiful
squares here knight d6 here
will just win material so here bishop
the b7
a very sneaky move by owen trying to get
morphe to go for bishop captures on
on h4 now with the idea that if well
let's show that bishop captures queen
captures and knight here
seems to be winning material for morphe
but um
the problem is after owen moves the rook
capturing the rook is way too ambitious
for example if you capture the rook then
rook captures on f4 and black is lost
this is coming
uh there's also the the immediate queen
to f2 checkmate as the bishop covers
the entire light square diagonal here
and here you are dead lost whatever you
play
so it's actually a sneaky idea by owen
to go for this bishop to b7 move
queen to d3 by morphy he just defends
the knight and then now comes
rook to f8 again going after this f4
pawn
but now morphy plays the absolute
strongest bishop captures queen captures
and now
well now morphy finds a beautiful move
which uh i know you see it but still
feel free to pause the video and uh well
find
the idea well i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting knight
f6
check uh and also for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show now the
point is the
the knight cannot be captured by the
pawn if you capture by the pawn it's
just queen g6 check king h8 and rook
captures on d7 and you're getting
checkmated
there's nothing you can do about this
there are no checks there are no tricks
it's
it's just game over you could uh give up
uh
uh give up the queen for example with
queen captures and g4 queen captures and
rook g8
the problem is you don't really care
queen captures rook captures and king
moves and
well it's just two rooks against the
rook and the bishop are still
completely winning the the bishop is
hanging and well the pawn will fall well
then the other rook will will join this
rook on the seventh rank
it it's just uh not playable so morphe
finds this fairly quickly
but of course owen goes for rook
captures he gives up the exchange we
have e captures on f6
and now queen captures on g4 with check
morphy blocks it of course now that he's
up material he wants to trade queens
and interestingly owen goes for it as
well if you
play something weird like let's say
queen h5 you're getting check made it
here so of course you you must trade
queens
so queen captures h captures and now
bishop to c6 just defending this pawn
and here after captures captures we
enter this
end game where it's two rooks against
the rook and bishop where morphy is down
upon
but up the exchange so a very very clear
advantage for morphy so let's see how
they do
morphe starts by bringing the king into
the game
which is definitely one what you want to
do king of six and now
g4 just taking away all of these squares
from the black king
uh and now h5 owen uh uh understands
this and he wants to create some
weaknesses morphe of course doesn't
capture he goes g5 with check he creates
a pass pawn
and the king f5 now and here we have
king the
e3 by morphy here morphe underestimates
uh
owens the knowledge of the endgame a
little bit king to g3
is much much better as it prevents this
pawn from reaching h4 here with king e3
uh morphe just gives owen too much time
to push his pass pawn so here he goes h4
rogue d2 the rook is ready to cover that
h square
so h3 sorry h file and now rook to h2
going after the pawn but now the problem
is
bishop g2 locks morphy's rook completely
out of the game we we could use the
yellow one for this i guess
and now the rook is out of the game the
pawn is already on h3 so how do you how
do you play this are you still uh better
even though
even though you're uh you know playing
with with an entrapped rook
okay morphe goes rook to c2 now with
some ideas of probably defending the
spawn and
giving up the rook for bishop and pawn
however d5 by owen and now you cannot
capture because the rook
the rook just hangs so here we have g6
by morphy g6 a very nice trick
uh that's well if if owen accepts this
then you can trade here on g2 but now it
comes with
check and after all the checks king has
to move and now you even get the trade
here and now it's three against two
morphe would very likely
draw this so here after g6 we have d
captures on c4 o and not one to be
tricked
uh creates a pass pawn of his own here
now there's a past h pawn and also a
pass c
pawn but now g7 by morphe and here the
immediate rook to g8 oh we knows that
this pawn is now extremely dangerous
we have rook captures on g2 morphe has
to do something about it
we have pawn captures and rook captures
defending his past pawn but now king of
six
owen just goes after the pawn uh and now
rook to c2 this pawn will fall
you might as well grab some other pawns
we have rook captures on g7
now comes rook captures on c4 and now
rook to g3 with
check king e4 and now rook to a3 here
going after the a2 pawn
and there's not much you can do about it
uh morphe played rook the c2 here
but now uh owen just played rook to a4
and it was
in this position on move 46 that paul
charles morphe resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done well
there is something to be done like you
you could play it out until the end but
point is after king here and king here
you will lose this pawn uh if the rook
moves you will also lose this pawn all
the black pawns are nicely defended so
there's it's it's not even not even that
hard of an end game to play and the
morphe i guess uh
as he uh was outplayed uh in an end game
where he was up material
respects owen uh plenty to resign in
this position
so it's uh it's very sorry not in this
position but in this position
so it's very interesting and i i i think
this is a very important game to show i
don't know if this is the exact game
uh where the owens defense the b6 move
got
the name oh in defense uh but i'm pretty
sure it should be i mean you've defeated
morphy with the black pieces with a
weird pawn move i i'm
pretty sure you you get to call this
defense your own so
the owen defense uh i'm pretty sure it's
uh due to this uh
uh game where he defeated uh the one and
only paul charles murphy
but now is where the things get really
interesting now
uh morphe challenged owen to a match but
to a match where morphy will be playing
with odds he will be down upon and the
move
uh and we are going to show a couple of
those games as they are very interesting
and well we'll see what happens there
when you know uh now the
the beast has been awakened so
uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it if you haven't seen
that video that i was talking about the
greco video do check it out it will be
in the description below and also if you
want to get
yourself or your you know your
girlfriend your boyfriend or your
friends at the bar in the library some
uh either a morphe shirt or a more or
either a barn shirt or a barn
mug the link will be the first thing you
see in the description
below so yeah uh once again i do hope
you enjoyed it i would like to thank
um alimadi uh tim tully jeffrey turner
kevin clark and austin
bryantal for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world the uh grand final
is almost upon us so thank y'all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day